let's go to eric from colorado eric
you're on there
hey david this is eric hey eric what's
going on
hey so i kind of had a question a little
bit of what the last caller said where
do you think that we would be if trump
was still elected and this war was still
going on
so i'm gonna be i'm not gonna i could
give you some totally cartoonish thing
where i could say like if trump was
president right now he would be
literally cheerleading putin's invasion
no no no no i think here's the way i
think this would have gone down if if
trump were president when putin invaded
ukraine
first trump would have done exactly what
he did
in the first couple days he would have
said putin smart putin savvy putin's
genius imagine that what great land he's
taking he would have said that at the
beginning
then
the entire world including
everybody around trump would have
started to say hey you can't be praising
putin putin's choosing to do this war of
aggression like you you got to back off
of it and much like trump did at cpac i
think trump would have turned around and
he would have started at least softly
supporting um
ukraine's defense of its land uh but but
i think that when it comes to
coordinating sanctions with our allies
the way that joe biden has been doing
trump would just completely fail and the
the discussions would be a disaster and
we would be humiliated and out of sync
with our allies rather than under biden
at least you could disagree with what's
being done but but at least it's sort of
like a coherent united plan i think
that's what would happen under trump
thank you and do you think that like
russia would have probably done more if
the united states would have been out of
nato uh under trump so
i i mean i don't know those hypoth i
don't i don't find tons of value in
those that type of hypothetical
necessarily that that requires a lot
more differences and assumptions i'm
just not sure
okay thank you so much for taking my
call david my pleasure there's eric from
colorado with a very
specific question
one of our sponsors today is bluechew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping